je crois que il était important qu'il
s'exprime enfin sur cette question du
communautarisme
ce que je constate sur la méthode c'est
que à chaque fois on a droit à un grand
déplacement de grands discours
ce qui est important ce sont les actes
pour l'instant sur ces sujets on a vu un
gouvernement qui était là était plutôt
timorés qui nous est pas nommer les
choses on voit bien que sur la
sémantique on parle pas de
communautarisme mais de séparatisme
on a un certain nombre de sujets qui
sont complètement éludé qui sont traités
avec naïveté et il a même par exemple
bas par exemple d'après la dg et si on a
quand même 150 quartiers qui sont
aujourd'hui aux mains les islamistes et
ça de ne pas de solutions concrètes pour
faire revenir la république dans ces
territoires ce qui pose quand même un
certain nombre de sujets